all right so it is spooky season
werewolf by night is out right now and
in this video we're gonna be breaking
down the story who this hairy little
wolf man is some of the Easter eggs and
theories along with our reaction and
review in this first and hopefully not
last Marvel special presentation uh a
special werewolf by night had long been
rumored as a Halloween special but kept
very quiet and it's kind of crazy to see
Marvel try their hand at something so
out of the box which could honestly open
the door for more supernatural horror
Marvel characters like Ghost Rider Damon
hellstrom or even Mephisto that dirty
demon dude is gonna show up soon mark my
words now if you enjoyed this video then
please shoot a silver bullet at that
like button and also don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns and Recaps like
this every full moon well actually it's
uh every day but full moon sounded
better never mind with that out of the
way a huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into werewolf by night
[Music]
now it opens on a new Marvel special
Presentation logo that I assume will be
the standard across all of these one-off
specials as we get the usual Marvel
Fanfare intro however this intro loses
its coloring and the music dips into a
horror-like chanting Orchestra already
showcasing the musical abilities of
Michael giaccino with added claw marks
leaning into the werewolf nature of the
story and a frankenstein-like
electricity shock transforms the overall
aesthetic into something more akin to
the 30s or 40s monster movie title cards
that this is pulling inspiration from
specifically Universal's The Wolfman
intro from 1941. there's a tapestry of
our six heroes from 2012's The Avengers
movie as the narrator says the known
universe
with its Heroes and Marvels even this
guy is puns as he continues with but
what of the darkness as we see Pages out
of an old textbook with what appears to
be a vampire potentially Dracula's true
form the Latin writing on the right can
be translated to a winged monster
effectively and completely corrupted
from virtue or piety the next Monster
appears to be a two-headed siren
essentially an alluring fish woman oh I
I can't say that oh okay
um woman of fish these monster
illustrations look like older versions
of the ones that are featured in the
from the files of Ulysses Bloodstone
comic issue who happens to be introduced
as the hunter in these illustrations
warding off that damn Sasquatch having a
similar look to his flashback scenes
from the Marvel presents Bloodstone
Comics there's also a mention of hunters
taking pride in what they do which is a
striking call out out to a certain
vampire Hunter we're supposed to see
pretty soon blade
how the [ __ ] are you out of your damn
mind no Ulysses Bloodstone is the reason
this werewolf by night story is taking
place Mr Bloodstone had originally been
a caveman kept alive for roughly 10 000
years due to the fragment of the Mystic
alien blood gem imbued in his chest bone
later referred to as the Bloodstone he
sought revenge against the evil extra
dimensional being the Hellfire Helix
that had killed his fellow tribes people
and from which the power of the
Bloodstone originated from sending waves
of monsters to stop him on his Path of
Revenge Bloodstone became an infamous
monster Slayer with the Latin stating
the Bloodstone family heroically fought
the monsters for the Salvation of men
using the power of the Bloodstone to Aid
him a weapon unlike any other was said
to Grant Bloodstone superhuman stamina
agility senses and a vast regenerative
Powers which prevented him from aging
over all of those centuries of his life
think of an Infinity gem like DLC pack
not as good as the originals but uh it's
still it still works however spoilers he
did and that's what brings all of the
hunters back to Bloodstone castle for
the evening his funeral the Latin
phrasing next to him gives us a theory
on how he potentially passed stating
this tearful Bloodstone Ulysses the
Seventh Son as far as the stones are
concerned is slain and his slain on the
last full moon of the year and at the
end of the blood or Bloodshed it's a
rough translation but full moon werewolf
death it's all connected man anyway it's
a ceremonial hunt involving all of these
ominous hunters from across the globe to
find out who will be the next to wield
the Bloodstone however there's a
slippery little monster man amongst them
we know this is Jack Russell but we'll
talk a little bit more about him a bit
later the hallway he passes through
though is chocked full of little details
the tapestries on the wall look similar
to those of the Bayo bayu tapestry
featuring The Battle of 1066 but instead
showing the fight against Monsters over
the centuries in different cultures all
of the writing on the wall translates to
things revolving around the world of
monsters and hunting them like a monster
known as a bad thing at best to attend
the Last Breath of Life wild dangers the
geese flee from Victory and death
honestly these are just nonsense at this
point the king lives to call to the
kingdom and the lyrics of the hit 1962
Bobby Pickett song Monster Mash
Jack admires the wall art win scene a
bit when he sees the depiction of a
werewolf being killed giving us a slight
hint hint nudge nudge at his own secret
and honestly could be one of his
long-lost hairy little relatives he
enters the main Lounge set up like a
hunter's Lodge with dozens of paintings
taxidermied monster heads other relics
across the centuries and Ulysses coffin
the paintings look similar to the
opening illustrations with Bloodstone
facing off against each of the monsters
there are a half dozen or so of these
monsters mounted on the wall of which
include familiar favorites like the
Sasquatch Yeti or Minotaur to more
obscure ones like the man fibian or even
chernobog the black keeping with the
different Hunters over the centuries we
can also see some Knight and gladiator
armor on the shelves as Jack admires
everything the Bloodstone is then shown
to be the only thing in color shining
brightly as Jack admires this is
interesting because it's the only color
that is breaking through that black and
white aesthetic of the special which I
think is similar to Thor love and
thunder and how powerful artifacts
reacted in the shadow realm everything
is devoid of color except the most
powerful of items which subtly shows us
that the Bloodstone is nothing to mess
with Jack talks with the Weight Watchers
version of Fat Bastard revealing that it
will be his 30th season and that the
ammunity amp and an amenity and amenity
seriously these words in their line of
work is very important which explains
how Jack is able to crash this party
Jack mentions he's had a couple fights
with the Vampire looking creature on the
wall joking that he's never looked more
alive I assume that this is Dracula
because he recognizes him and in the
comics werewolf by Knight did have a
couple run-ins with Mr Acula it's a
little nod but also makes me think that
this is set outside of the 616 Universe
because they won't waste a huge blade
villain on just you know a little
reference like this Elsa Bloodstone
crashes the party scene is almost an
outcast returning home after being away
for decades now in the comics Elsa was
also a monster hunter much like her
father likened to that of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer having more of an
attitude about doing things her own way
it was said that her father pushed her
almost in an abusive sense to become
this great Monster Hunter much like
himself but instead this manipulation
sounds like it drove Elsa away for all
of these years not visiting the
Bloodstone Castle until now demanding
that she is the rightful heir to the
Bloodstone varusa's evil stepmother
angle gives off similarities to maleva
the Gypsy sorceress from the original
1941 Wolfman movie varusa goes around
the room listing off everyone's kill
count which is the like awarding little
gold stars in grade school as we get a
better look at each of these Hunters
barasso has 26 Azrael has 37. Lyon has
43 Joven with an impressive 57 and Jack
well over 100. even him being a bit
surprised by that number again hinting
that he maybe doesn't belong vorusa
refers to the group as death dealers
which could be a slight nod to the
villain of Shang Chi that goes by the
same name Elsa being an outcast amongst
these other Hunters doesn't have her
kill count listed off potentially
meaning that it's secretive or that she
actually doesn't have any monsters under
her belt the other Hunters also Sports
some sort of facial feature or deformity
whether it be a nose ring scar no
eyebrows face paint while Elsa is just
herself subliminally showing that she
doesn't belong Elsa interrupts a varusa
moving a table just like Will Smith does
in Men in Black
you want to get down on this
Marvel likes their humor as you can see
of this end up disclaimer on the back of
Ulysses coffin and in front of his
coffin is a sword crossed with his
iconic shotgun he favored in the comics
Billy Swann who's this little dude just
cranking away is essentially the Igor
character in all of the Frankenstein
monster movies that's there to do you
know essentially the busy work in this
case Crank That zombie boy
Ulysses is cranked out like some
run-down Chuck E cheese animatronic and
gives the hunters the mission of the
evening to me Ulysses kind of looks like
the zombie AKA Simon Garth from the
comics but I guess all zombies look the
same to me I I didn't mean that I'm not
zombies please don't cancel me but yeah
like an old Haunted Mansion animatronic
Ulysses States a powerful monster will
be released in the sacred grounds with
the hunters having to Hunger Games it
slain the monster and whoever does will
be the rightful bearer of the Bloodstone
own but the catch is that the Bloodstone
will be affixed to the hide of the
monster both weakening it great I love
to hear that while also making it very
very angry reinforcing The Hunger Games
Battle Royale treatment each of the
hunters must sacrifice their Bloodstone
pendants to participate in the hunt
essentially drawing straws for the order
of entering the sacred grounds Jack
receives the Saxon rune for Faye meaning
F or first but also is the symbol for
wealth or cattle which can then be
broken down further into Prosperity luck
or New Beginnings being quite a
foreshadow at how all of this turns out
for him jack is the first to enter the
maze following a relative of the Flaming
Guitar Man from Mad Max Fury Road who
had a love for the tuba I guess art
imitates Life The Hunters recite a
hunter's oath
to rid this land of its Abominations a
name drop who'da thought that Blonsky
would be in She-Hulk and werewolf by
night at the same time but now I
couldn't find any reference to the
actual oath that they speak but it does
feel similar to the speeches or prayers
from Boondock Saints like a promise
before Taking Lives Elsa comes across an
old timey record player playing Vera
Lynn's wishing will make it so from
1939.
[Music]
foreign
the lyrics are a clever bit of
foreshadowing and backstory for Elsa
meaning she had wishes as a child I'm
guessing to be a great Monster Hunter
like her father but things went awry
though she is older now wish again
obviously being the rightfulbearer of
the Bloodstone and who knows it could
happen now Jack crosses paths with Elsa
and here we can kind of infer that both
of these two are kind of unlike the
other Hunters being more pacifist
avoiding confrontation as Jax suggests
they just kind of pass each other by
Joven swoops in like Gimli trying to
take them out only to be taken out like
a chump Elsa steals his ax and Joven
curses death upon the hit 1994 movie
Lassie gas is coming for you
uh ex what do you mean he he's Scottish
oh
huh a nice attention to detail here are
the two quick cigarette Burns in the top
right corner of the screen this is a
term used in filmmaking because they
look like little Burns caused by actual
cigarettes but they indicate that a
change of reels is coming in this case a
scene change the more you know you're
welcome Elsa crosses some corroded hand
in Footprints so you know Quentin
Tarantino isn't far away foot humor it's
good for the soul anyway giving us
further hints at the man or potentially
thing that is hunting them as she passes
the corridor the light fixtures almost
look like upside down crosses which in
pop culture has gained Fame as a demonic
symbol Elsa's altercation with liorn
results in him giving her a hand and is
hella brutal because he is squirting
blood all over the place which oddly
enough reminded me of Adam's Family
Values the talent show scene it's just
squirting everywhere through this
fighting we can see that Elsa has been
trained maybe not by her father but
she's proficient enough I mean it left
Lyon
speechless
yeah he uh well he's dead Jack is
grabbed by the mystery monster we've
heard so much about which turns out to
be man thing now this monster is
interesting because he's part man and uh
well well part part thing yeah in the
comics man thing used to be Dr Theodore
Salas who was a biochemist working in
the Everglades he was basically
attempting to recreate the super soldier
serum however after aim tried to steal
his research he injected himself with
the serum crashed his car into a magical
swamp and ended up turning into the slow
moving swamp monster called man thing
possessing a variety of abilities now
MCU origin wise this could be the same
we're not entirely sure but there is a
rumored man thing special in the works
so we may get some answers very soon
another thing about man thing is that
the magical swamp that he dwells in is a
Nexus to all realities essentially a
pathway to any and all realities think
the Monsters Inc door technology but
only one singular door and man thing is
basically the guardian of it there was
actually a reference to this and Nexus
events in one of the Wanda vision
commercials featuring a pill called
Nexus that could theoretically take you
to any reality you wanted so a subtle
connection oh Kev dog may lean into
later down the road Jack is actually
Undercover on a rescue mission to rescue
his old buddy man thing working on an
Escape Plan he's locked into a crypt
with Elsa learning more about one
another along with a proper finally
introduction from Jack Russell stating
his family was a bit different aside
from Jack's name being a pun of a dog I
mean Jack Russell Jack Jack Russell
Terrier I can't be the only one he is
well he is so werewolf essentially a
descendant of Russell had been inflicted
by a werewolf's curse sentries earlier
when fighting Dracula hint hint back to
the vampire and this passed on
generation to generation making Russell
the current werewolf By Night his
Origins are a bit messy ranging from
almost a Teen Wolf approach with him
finding out about his power when he
turned 18 to his ancestors having been
involved in finding pages to the dark
hold when turning into the Savage
werewolf Jack possesses all of the
traits and abilities you'd think comes
along with that gluten intolerance
silver being one of the biggest
weaknesses and he does lose his
intellect in the transformation becoming
a Savage Beast however in the comics
years later after training Russell was
able to hone in on this allowing his
intellect to stay with him similar to
kind of what we saw with smart Hulk in
end game the conversation between Elsa
and Jack humanizes them from the other
Hunters showing that each of them kind
of has alternative motives than the
deadly Hunger Games that are afoot I
really enjoyed this softer moment
between the characters and how they kind
of connect on this differing family
Dynamics showing how we uh kind of
perceive them as monsters when actually
they are far from but the Crypt also has
a handful of Easter eggs with the names
on each of the tombs Jacob Howell is is
a combination of Jacob Balcom and Matt
Howell who are the hosts of The Werewolf
By Night podcast David long is a prop
Master who's worked on some previous MCU
projects Brandon clela is an art
director Griffith Burke could refer to
job Burke the son of man thing and
Beverly could be a reference to Beverly
Switzer Howard the Duck's girlfriend uh
this one we get a better look at man
thing dissolving Joven into effectively
nothingness while his screams sound like
Marv from Home Alone Elsa uses man
thing's real name of Ted to calm down
the wild beast and gain his trust they
then Escape through the maze which looks
identical to Hulk chasing Black Widow on
the Hello carrier in The Avengers man
thing escaping into the Wilderness
almost feels like a Frankenstein's
monster type escape with the innocence
of the monster being revealed when the
Bloodstone is revealed similar to the
innocence of Frankenstein's monster the
smiles and dwelling music is cut short
when Jack attempts to pick up the
Bloodstone only to be blasted back the
Bloodstone had been used to ward off
monsters much like we saw in the opening
illustrations revealing that Jack even
though we already knew this is in fact a
monster there's a couple more cigarette
Burns as the scene changes over to Jack
and Elsa in quite a hairy situation Jack
reveals he's not a human human per se
while cleverly scratching behind his ear
like a dog in order to keep Elsa safe he
grabs her scent like a dog he needs to
remember this and tells Elsa no matter
what do not break eye contact this is
because in some species of predators the
worst thing you can do is look away from
them like Kevin's spoilers himself oh
dear no Elsa thinks this is crazy but uh
lets it Go asking if it had worked
before Jack softly States yes once
before suggesting that maybe a wife
loved one or family member was spared
previously while so many others had
unfortunately been taken by his curse
this whole sequence with verusa taunting
Jack in the cage feels very similar to
the cage scene from Silence of the Lambs
maybe just as bloody as varusa then uses
the Bloodstone to transform Jack an
interesting thing about this whole
Bloodstone is that it looks like it uses
some form of chaos Magic from the red
glow the way the energy waves flow
through the air and even creates a
similar lens flare to what we saw when
Scarlet witched used her attack so if
you were unsure about its power level
now you know the transformation of Jack
into the werewolf by night is in line
with you know other werewolf-like
Transformations being shrouded in the
shadows as we see him more from a human
into a much more Savage Beast some of
are enough I think Jurassic Park had a
decent influence on this because Jack
grabbing varusa towards the cage and
then being shocked by all of the guards
instantly took me to the opening scene
of Jurassic Park with the Raptor ripping
a worker in and then they have to go and
shock it Jack's screams even sounds
similar resulting in a pissed off wolf
man this whole action sequence is
straight up banana sandwiches Jack is
absolutely brutal fighting like a
scrappy bar brawler at 2AM not paying
their tab more so than a complete
monster but I was surprised by how
graphic and bloody it was not only from
Jack's action I mean he did do a Mike
Tyson ear bite on this dude but also
with Elsa fighting off the other Hunters
it even feels like a first person
shooter in a sense with the blood
splattering against the lens and
remaining there while the action
continues to escalate Elsa uses Jack's
real name to help calm him down much
like she used teddies earlier when
talking with man thing but Jack also
remembers her scent and hurt not
breaking eye contact this scene is great
because it shows how jack isn't fully a
monster and how Elsa even though a
monster hunter fully realizes she can be
gentle and reason with these beasts
rather than you know acts of violence
towards them the old traditional way of
hunting is literally ended with man
thing crispy frying virusa and tossing
her like a white Goodman dodgeball
straight into Ulysses coffin symbolizing
the end of an era of hunting the ending
is a two-part conclusion in a sense with
it first focusing on Elsa taking on the
role of leader of this new regime of
Monster Hunters with Billy Swann aka the
Igor character from earlier catering to
his new master a soft Melody from Wizard
of Oz's Somewhere Over the Rainbow
begins to play as color bleeds out of
the Bloodstone oh wow that's uh that's
two on the nose to bring new life to
Elsa and the entire screen it sort of
reminded me of Pleasantville with all of
the color filling the screen and we see
Elsa's familiar red outfit that she
Sports in the comics while the song has
a deeper meaning of hope that bad times
will be over one day symbolizing the
Elsa and the Bloodstone Legacy are on to
better times instead of hunting monsters
she's now working with them the idea of
opening up to people without prejudice
and shows that the hunters were actually
the real monsters all along or you know
some inspirational mumbo jumbo you know
what I'm saying the song continues to
play as Jack and man thing are okay
there's a fun banter between the two
about always you know who's rescuing who
and then they suggest that they go grab
some sushi together it's more of a fun
end cap but the sushi bit feels like
it's taking a note from when Tony and
the others go and gets Shawarma at the
end of The Avengers there's also some
random objects at the camp including
luggage French Press cowbell playing
cards a guitar and Payphone now a pay
phone was something people used to I'm
not gonna mansplain playing a pay phone
to you you get it dial down the center
with
1-800-c-a-l-l-a-t-t okay okay okay I'm
done I promise man thing probably
grabbed all of these random objects from
his Nexus to all realities portal that
we mentioned earlier but also shows that
he is entirely Off the Grid the special
comes to a close with the classic the
end titling which is identical to 1941's
Citizen Kane and also used in 2019's the
joker now the special seems fairly
self-contained without referencing much
of the canonized MCU we know so there
aren't many theories on where you know
this could go hell Somewhere Over the
Rainbow could be interpreted as this
story happening in a completely
different Multiverse a fever dream in a
sense but that kind of feels like a
dirty Wizard of Oz cop out with rumored
specials for both Elsa Bloodstone and
man thing in the works these could be
set up to tell almost a prologue to this
with the origins of man thing and an
epilogue with Elsa showing off where the
Bloodstone Legacy takes her potentially
weaving into the upcoming blade movie
hey she's into monsters he's into
vampires it could happen if Marvel
followed this Theory while still making
these self-contained stories I'd be on
board they could even go as far as you
know introducing Elsa's brother being
the antagonist vying for the Bloodstone
or werewolf by Knight and man thing
creating some sort of
Monster Squad overall though werewolf by
night is probably my favorite project
out of phase four so far with it
adapting this like old school 40s
monster movie aesthetic it's grounded
but weird serious but fun happy but
violent like the Carnage was an
interesting change of pace for Marvel
and honestly this was one hell of a
gamble out of the box experiment that I
think warrants a couple more of these
one-off specials this might be the way
about going with things rather than
making everything meticulously connected
because it entirely works on its own
sure I was waiting for a post-credit
stinger of mahersha Ali's blade to walk
in but it wasn't needed and you know who
made all of this work so well together
his name was Mike [ __ ] Mike his
musical score instantly set the mood and
the love for older monster movies can
thoroughly be seen throughout this even
down to the fake cigarette Burns in the
corners the biggest flea on this
werewolf is that I would wish that it
was a feature length you know the 50-ish
minute length does help to keep things
tight but there is so much more about
this world these characters the
relationships hell even the backstory
and lore for characters we didn't even
see now this could all be remedied with
the rumor of more of these Marvel
special presentations slowly building a
world of Standalone Supernatural
monsters half of me wants the connection
while the other half is completely fine
with what we got but obviously I would
love to hear your thoughts no seriously
let me know what did you think of
werewolf by night or rather wbn like all
of us cool kids are saying and if these
one-off specials are the next step in
the right direction for Marvel Studios
we're currently running a competition
right now giving away three copies of
Thor love and thunder on the 15th of
October and how you get entered all you
got to do is like this video make sure
to subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment Down Below on your
thoughts of werewolf by night we picked
the comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last month
are on screen right now so if that is
you message Paul on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch be sure to check out some of our
other cool videos right over there
whether it be our She-Hulk breakdowns or
Rick and Morty season 6 coverage with
that out of the way thanks for sticking
through this video I've been Jared and
it's unfortunate you're watching this on
a full moon because
sorry that was a hairball thanks you're
the best bye-bye now